hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar
population bottlenecks strongly affect
the evolutionary dynamics of antibiotic
persistence
i am jennifer woods of labyrinth and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and brought to you by
inscripta to learn more
visit inscripta.com we
encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits window at the bottom of your
screen to obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
braum vondenberg
postdoctoral researcher k.u lubin
fwo vib center for microbiology
brahm you may now begin your
presentation
hi so good evening to you all or good
morning or
noon whatever time zone you're in and
thanks for the nice introduction
uh jennifer and also obviously uh thanks
to inscripta and laproots for giving me
the opportunity to
to share the work that we've done using
the inscripta
technology today i will be showing you
that studying persistence well a type of
resilience to antibiotics that is
is important and specifically that
studying
its evolutionary dynamics in the context
of
bottlenecks population bottlenecks makes
sense to better understand
our current battle against bacterial
infections
in doing so we discovered that the
fitness landscape of persistence
likely is rugged and that these
bottlenecks therefore can have
strong impact on not only the course but
also the
outcome of evolution so as
uh jennifer already told you i'm a
long-term
postdoc in the lab of yomi heals so the
older person
in in the figure leading our group at
keuler
i'm funded by fwo but the the talk of
today is actually uh mostly spare headed
by
dr ettel bindles it's a former student
that i co-supervised and who recently
uh defended her phd and actually she's
not in the lab anymore sadly
she she went went on to better
better future
and she's pursuing now a postdoc at the
lab of tanya stadler
at eth in basel obviously we also got
some support from other members of our
lab
and also of professor tom vensliers a
professor at keuler
an expert in biostatistics and
computational biology
and of course the reason that i'm giving
the talk of
for you today uh we got some support by
inscripta
who actually offered us the opportunity
to to work
with their technology at an early stage
um
and the reason that we got into contact
with inscripta is through
vip vib is one of our sponsors but it's
also a research
institute and they and they actually
offer us not only extra funding but also
this this support tagwatch team that
actually looks out for these new
technologies now um
let's go to the to the first intro
because i will give some intro on on uh
this topic i think that's needed the
more most important topic is for sure
antibiotic persistence this is
the phenotype that we in our lab study
on bacteria
very often in many many projects and
many of you
probably think of of antibiotic
persistence as
fcs we know this antibiotic resistance
we've heard of it it's a big problem
and although resistance and persistence
are very similar at many aspects
they do differ quite strongly at
important aspects for this talk so let's
first
go go and define these things so indeed
on the left you can see the predictions
of of how many deaths we will suffer
annually
from failing antibiotic treatments
mostly because of antibiotic
resistance and this 10 million deaths in
2050 it's it's a prediction so the the
numbers you can debate up on them
but what what is not debatable is the
growing incidence of resistance and and
indeed
this estimation of of these numbers this
antibiotic crisis is mostly
uh caused by uh by resistance and what
is resistance that is shown on the right
with resistance we mean that bacteria
acquire the capacity to grow
under elevated drug concentrations so in
green you see a sensitive strain
and in red you see a strain that has
acquired resistance it can grow at much
higher levels of antibiotics and
a resistance level we quantify with this
concentration at which
growth can still be inhibited the lowest
concentration
that can still inhibit growth is the
minimum inhibitory concentration or
mi the mic values go up
as resistance increases you also have
a commercial assays on the
on the right slide this strip is
actually a gradient or contains a
gradient of
antibiotics and it produces a growth
halo
and then the interface between the
growth
halo and and the growth zone that's then
defined as mic it's a bit more easy to
use that strip
for example in a clinical setting and
measuring these mic values is well
established nowadays many people do it
it's quite easy to do
and obviously in a clinical setting it's
it's very easy to do as well and and
therefore often done
and even we have these uh databases of
mic values for example the ucas database
uh that contains a lot of mic values of
a lot of species towards a lot of
antibiotics
which can be used then decide to decide
whether a level is
characterized as a resistance or not
resistant
level now resistance is well studied
and and mostly most of the mechanisms
are well known i would say
it's mostly caused by mutations or by
genetic elements that that
are are transferred and these genetic
changes
they mostly impair drug target binding
and that will be later important if we
compare it to tolerance and persistence
and since its link between mutations and
phenotype is quite strong
this phenotype of resistance is
therefore genetically inherited
and passed on to the daughter cells and
often very often also population might
express
now in contrast
to not being inhibited at a certain
drug concentration there's a second
option of bacteria to evade
drug action and another option would be
especially if you think about
bactericidal drugs so drugs that kill
bacteria
is to simply survive treatment and
that's what we call
tolerance and what would happen if you
have a bacterium that cannot grow
in in high concentrations of antibiotics
but are simply not
killed then this mic value if you would
use the standard test that is used in
clinical settings
this mic value would actually not change
why not because if it would change then
obviously we would speak of resistance
so the tolerance level can actually not
be defined as the mic but as the killing
rate
and that is shown on on the bottom graph
of the browner
reference figure where you can follow
the number of viable cells in time
during
treatment and if you then look at the
susceptible strain
or population this this these numbers go
down quite quickly
the more tolerant strain although it is
still killed it's killed
much more slowly and there is even so
there
are have been some attempts because this
is quite laborious thing to do
there have been some some attempts to um
to
make it easier especially for the
clinical setting to measure tolerance
for example the group of natalie balaban
in israel
they've come up with this minimal
duration of killing the mdk
to kill 99 of the population
but then again it would still require a
quite laborious
setup to measure this mdk-99
now inherently you cannot be tolerant to
bacteriostatic antibiotics so you need a
bactericidal drug to speak of
tolerance and also to speak of
persistence and i will come to that
later
in contrast to resistance this tolerance
is also much more
sensitive towards environmental
conditions so this
killing rate can be changed quite
strongly depending
on the specific conditions in which you
measure them
and basically that's also one of the
reasons along with the with a laborious
way of
measuring uh tolerance is that it's not
or
seldomly used or measured in clinical
setting or
looked after in during drug design
now the mechanisms since it's also less
studied in general the mechanisms are
less clear
as for resistance but most of the
mechanisms or most of the
results kind of indicate that
some form of dormancy or inactivity is
is actually underlying this tolerance
phenotype now if we look
now that we defined torrance if you look
at defining persistence
it becomes quite easy because
persistence is actually a specific
type of tolerance in a subset of cells
and we call these cells persisters and
as it is a specific type of tolerance
um basically many of the aspects on the
left actually also apply on the right so
again there would be no change in mic
value
and to quantify persistence you need to
make those
killing curves you need to follow the
viable cells
in time during a drug treatment
now unlike tolerance what you would see
then
is not a slower uniformic killing rate
like you see on the left but what you
would see is
a biphasic killing um as you can see on
the right
so initially you would kill most of your
sensitive
wild-type cells but then after a while
in the persistent population or the
population that has
persisters only persisters would be
still alive
and your killing will go down now to
quantify the persistence
level there are a few ways to do this
mostly what is done is people use
one time point of treatment and quantify
the survival at that time and as long as
that time point is on the persister
plateau we would call it so the second
slower killing rate plateau you're
usually fine
the more correct way to do it would be
to really determine those biphasic
killing curves
in full and fit them with an equation
that is shown here
and this equation actually has two terms
the killing rate of normal cells
and the killing rate of persister cells
so k
n and kp and from this equation
you can then estimate the number of
persisters which is in capital p
or the number of normal cells which
obviously you know
there are way a lot of other ways to
quantify persistence you could even
go as crazy and quantify the killing
rate of the second killing
phase or again the group of professor
balaban in israel came up with the
mdk 99.99 or the time
the duration of treatment to kill 99.99
of the population but given that then
you define
your persistence as being lower than
0.01 percent of your population
i think you already bias your your
definition a bit
so i'm not really the biggest fan and
it's not popularly
used anyway now if we zoom into
persistence
it's very important to realize that this
is a form of phenotypic variation
so you really can think of it as a
normal cell
being switched to a persister cell or a
persister cell being switched
back to a normal cell and that this
tolerance of this persistent cell is
only transient in time
because of this the link between the
phenotype
and the genotype is much much weaker so
tolerance is genetically the torrent
state of the persister cell is
genetically not inherited to the
daughter cells
and that will be important for the
remainder of my talk
unlike resistance persisters actually
have
most if not all strains and species
obviously you have a lot of publication
bias there
but lately people are seeing that
there's a massive variation in the level
of persister levels in in the amount of
resistors
present in each of the strains even if
you study them under the same conditions
because indeed
also or similarly to tolerance
the environmental environmental
conditions are tremendously important
to determine those switching rates or
the resistor level
as such now why these different
isolates or strains or species have this
kind of a variation it's not
completely clear but the fact that all
of them have
at least some persisters as has probably
to do with the fact that it is believed
to be
that resistance is believed to be a bad
hedging strategy so some sort of
insurance strategy against disasters
that struck
all of a sudden and that are quite
important that would kill your entire
population in contrast to resistance
it also protects against multiple drugs
high concentration sometimes even
other stresses as well and like
tolerance the mechanisms are very often
not that
clear many people detect different
molecular mechanisms that are important
most of them are related to dormancy or
inactivity as for tolerance
but i will not go into detail about that
today
and people believe that they're
important for the chronic nature of some
infections
and we also showed and i will come back
to that later
that persistence can be a catalyst for
resistance development
now if you then compare them head to
head and i will go quickly so
in green you have a population where
where you have a few resistant mutants
in yellow
you have a population where you have a
few phenotypic variants persisters
they would be killed the same way in a
first treatment
all of the sensitive cells would be
killed quite quickly but then
as in as soon as those sensitive cells
are killed
the green cells since they are resistant
they can start growing again
albeit slowly while the yellow cells the
persister cells don't do
this if you switch them to a fresh
medium
then the green cells obviously they make
up a population of
entirely composed entirely of resistant
cells
while the yellow cells they actually
switch back to a normal cell state they
take a while sometimes there's a lag
phase sometimes
and then they actually make up a
population that is
again containing a few resistors and a
lot of sensitive cells so a second
treatment
would actually mean nothing for the
green population they're all resistant
anyway
but would result in again a biphasic
killing curve in
the case of persistence then you could
ask yourself but why do you study
evolutionary dynamics of persistence if
if the tolerance the phenotypic
tolerance is not genetically determined
and that's a bit of a confusing thing i
must agree but you have to realize that
although on single cell level
the tolerance is not heritable other
aspects of
persistence are genetically encoded most
importantly the number of persister
cells
on the population level within this
population
maybe also the lag time of resistors or
the killing rate of those resistors
how they how they are depending on the
environment all those things
are genetically encoded at least in one
way or another
so indeed you can obtain mutants with an
altered resistance level
and that's also why you can study
persistence and resistance evolution
although especially when i started my
phd which is already a while ago
at that time it was quite heavily
understudied which is weird because
there are a lot of signs
already at that time that showed that
indeed persistence evolution is a thing
that it happens and that it's important
so what we
saw already at that time was that
different isolates
actually showed widely different
resistor levels which is weird because
there must be some evolutionary pressure
causing this
especially if you if you assess them on
the same in the same
test another strong indication that
evolution is important
for presister levels is that late
isolates from chronic
infections that have been treated quite
heavily with antibiotics
is that they show often very high or
higher
resistor levels compared to those
initial clones
and you also have those eco-evolutionary
models on bad hedging
that predict that if resistance would
evolve but also that
there's an evolutionary stable state of
the persister level
and that's roughly that correlates
roughly inversely with the times
good times in between treatments if you
think about it
on an evolutionary scale so basically
this was the start of my phd and i asked
myself then a few questions
how does resistance evolve how does
persistence and its evolution how does
that affect
resistance development and which
mechanisms of the plethora of mechanisms
that we found in vitro
which mechanisms make sense in light of
the solution and you can already see
that those
questions are quite open-ended not
really the very focused ones you would
write in
a grant application but in in
in studying those things we definitely
found a lot of interesting things and
actually
a lot of other students could continue
on on on these questions
as well so i first
came up with an a setup an evolutionary
setup on the left
top you can see this where i would grow
my e coli cells overnight to stationary
phase
treat them with a high dose of
antibiotics well above the mic in this
case we used
amino glycoside antibiotics those
treatments would result only in
persisters being alive
those sculptures would then be washed
and diluted into fresh medium
to repeat the cycle and what we would
see then is shown on the on the right
graphs
a very quick and very strong evolution
towards strong
to towards higher survival levels so
these
data points are averages of 9 to 10
populations
and you can see that for the four
antibiotics that i show here
we start off at a 0.1 survival or lower
and very quickly after two three rounds
you actually end up with
survival levels close to 100 percent
even
now in this paper in in nature
microbiology in 2016 which basically
started the evolutionary study of
persistence in our lab
we've we've shown that this is not
resistance that indeed
we still have this is actually evolution
of persistence
we also showed that this is very
stationary phase specific
as we also designed our evolution
experiment that way
and we saw costs attached to these high
resistor levels especially in drug-free
conditions
obviously under treatment they have a
high benefit compared to the wild type
but in in cost in drug-free conditions
they have a pretty high cost
and we also shown we have we've also
shown in that paper that
basically the the predictions by bad
hedging models
are true so that if you would treat less
frequently than then once daily
those curves would actually go down
would show
slower and less extreme evolution and we
found that that single mutations are
causal to the phenotype
now as i said this is this was a start
to to study evolution of persistence in
our lab we've
repeated this trick in an aac
publication
in other in other pathogens basically
the escape pathogens
salmonella also europathogenic strain of
e coli
all of them basically show the same kind
of
trends where if you treat very
frequently you end up
very fast with very high survival levels
without any resistance
now brilliant minds think alike or
that's at least what i
tend to believe or want to believe
because around the time that we were
doing these experiments
other labs published similar approaches
uh most notably the
friedman paper in 2014
by the by the balaban group in israel
they have shown that if they treat daily
or repeatedly
upon dilution of a stationary face
culture
in fresh medium they would also get
very high tolerance levels very quickly
lucas mesler's group have done has done
similar work in the bestram
lucas smithless in the bertram group has
done similar work
with staphylococcus aureus and recently
in the last years
we've actually got the third modi
operandi where
they didn't either they didn't treat in
in stationary phase like we did or they
didn't treat upon dilution in fresh
medium like
the treatment paper did but they
actually treated exactly in the middle
of exponential phase so basically now
you have these
three schools let's say of doing
evolution experiments
with experiments with persistence but
besides doing these frequent treatments
and observing that you can obtain high
levels
i also believe that in the last years
we've taken the
evolutionary study of persistence to a
level or a next level
which i categorize in three parts let's
say so
the most important one is that we've
shown that tolerance and evolution of
torrents
invites resistance development and this
was first shown again by natalie balaban
where she showed and this is shown on
the figure on the right hand side if she
continued her
evolution experiment that she would
always first get these
tolerance mutations in yellow or in blue
and then only
afterwards she would develop resistance
in your e coli populations
always in a background of a more
tolerant strain
and that's logic if you think about it
right if you have a more tolerant strain
you have much more
survivors therefore the chance of you
developing or
of the bacteria to develop resistance is
much higher so this is a game of numbers
we showed actually ethel
showed that if you have a highly
tolerant strain or a more persistent
strain
generally you also have an increased
metagenesis so it's not only a game of
numbers
but because of this higher
methodogenesis you also get in blue you
can see this on the right hand graph
the oppbb strain which is a highly
persistent strain
you get a very quick development of
resistance
resistance much quicker than the wild
type does in black
or than a lower resistor strain does in
green
and lately uh the group of of
dt hearts showed uh in its
uh publication nature that resistance
can also form a pool of horizontal gene
transfer
uh that that can happen uh more more so
with more tolerant strains and
it was also shown that tolerance can
also
catalyze the development of resistance
to drug combinations which is usually
believed to be much more difficult and
then two other things that are
likely to to expand in the future is the
study of apostatic interactions between
mutations that affect resistance and
persistence
or mutations that affect resistance only
and so on
one publication showed that already for
resistance mutations and persistence
mutations that combined
increase tolerance much more than you
would expect to based on their
separate effects and then very lately
uh we saw two large-scale in vitro
in vivo observatory studies where they
examined isolates of in this case
pseudomonas adigenosa during
fibrosis basins and they basically
confirmed
what we've seen in vivo in vitro already
on the evolution
of persistence that that happens first
it catalyzes also resistance in these
cases so
that's very nice to see
now to the to the focus of this study i
know it took a while
but we wanted to know what bottlenecks
would do on
on these evolutionary dynamics of
resistance and that was really
ethel's work now why why focus on
bottlenecks right why is that why is
that important
well to start bottlenecks are inherently
important
right um in in evolution because they
basically are a balance
or they they cause a balance between the
the force of
natural selection and the strength of
drift
under very small populations that only
have one cell for example there is no
such thing as natural selection
and drift randomness is very strong and
basically all mutations can accumulate
and fixate as long as they're not very
very lethal
not only are they important in general
evolution but also they're quite
important if you think about
infections because there they're
frequently encountered so bacteria
they either transfer from one host to
another from one patient to another
and often this is involved in reduction
strong reductions in population size
but also if you think about treatments
we impose strong bottlenecks
on on infections on populations that
cause infections because of treatments
and luck
hopefully we we completely eradicate
them but sometimes that's not the case
so
therefore bottlenecks can be important
in evolution as well
and also because simply there's nothing
known on how bottlenecks affects
evolution of persistence so that makes
it inherently
important or at least interesting to
study
while there's nothing known on
specifically how how it affects
persistence evolution
there are obviously a lot of models and
and other studies on other
uh traits that that made us
form a few hypotheses what would happen
under smaller bottlenecks
um first since smaller bottlenecks
um actually
make you sample or make makes a
population sample the fitness landscape
sub-optimally i will show that later we
expect
the evolution to lead to sub-optimal
outcomes
since populations are smaller or the
bottlenecks
are definitely smaller we also expect a
lower mutation supply
so a slower evolution and perhaps a
longer waiting time
since the effective population size is
smaller
we also thought of thought that that
the few mutations that will occur that
they will actually
fix way quicker because it's only a
smaller population that they have to
that they have to fix in let's say
so we expect the lower intra population
diversity so the diversity within a
population
we believe is should be lower and if you
look at different population since
populations will randomly sample
the genotype space each of those
populations will do that
we expect a higher inter population
diversity but
most of these hypotheses are highly
dependent on the topography of the
fitness landscape and with that i mean
these two graphs that i showed you here
the the
fitness landscape on top actually shows
in the plane
all the possible genotypes reduction
obviously of all of the possible
genotypes
and then the height of the peaks shows a
fitness
shows the fitness and in this case also
the tolerance levels
if you have in this very simple and yeah
weird simplistic fitness landscape
if you only have one peak and then it
doesn't really matter whether you have
large populations or small populations
each population will eventually both
towards this
one high peak high fitness peak now if
you have the
the situation in the bottom which is
much more complex you have a lot of
sub-optimal peaks at different locations
you also have sally's
then the size of your population matters
a lot so the red population
actually contains a lot of different
genotypes at the start and therefore
all of the replica populations will
likely evolve towards this
peak in the middle that is also the
highest peak now
if you take a smaller population then it
highly depends
on which population you take by accident
you can and
you can start with a yellow population
that is more closely to the peak on the
left
top or you can start with the blue
population
and that is more to the bottom as a
result
those two populations they will evolve
differently
and they will end up potentially at
different
sub-optimal peaks so those were the
hypothesis to start with now to
to examine this ethyl had to adjust my
setup
slightly so that she could do way more
replica populations so instead of large
volumes
in flask she used microtiter plates and
she used the same cycle so a growth
cycle of 19 hours
and then a treatment of 5 hours and in
between obviously she washed
to remove the antibiotic but she also
imposed
bottlenecks so taking only a certain
fraction of the treated
volume to inoculate the next cycle
right between a 1 to 500 and a 1 to 10
dilution and in doing this
evolution experiment she did 40
populations per
bottleneck conditions she obtained
well the evolution that you can see on
the right hand side
where the red curve the 1 to 10 dilution
showed resembles resembled quite
strongly the the outcome that i had in
the larger volumes a very quick and very
strong evolution
and the smaller the bottleneck becomes
the slower and the more extreme
and also the longer we had to wait
for evolution to start off and
to quantify these three parameters so
the speed
the extent and the waiting time we
fitted this
data with a model that describes
basically the spread of a single mutant
in a population and and this model
that you can see there below the graph
it contains a few terms that are
interesting so the p
is the persister fraction and you can
see there an
s this is basically the slope or speed
of of um of evolution of the graph of
the sigmoidal graph
and then the lambda factor is basically
the lag time or the waiting time
um that that population needed
for a mutation to occur so i forgot to
say all these points that you show
are obviously averages of many evolution
experiments
that i don't show but that you can look
up in in the
mba paper uh of ethel
so if if she did this so yes indeed
that's what we expect those three errors
or
what we see if she looked at those three
parameters then you can indeed see that
bottlenecking restrains evolution so not
only
is the resistor fraction the end
persister fraction
lower at smaller population bottlenecks
but also is the rate or the speed of
adaptation lower at lower bottlenecks
and is the lag of adaptation larger
at lower bottlenecks so all these things
significantly
correlate the way we expect them to
under our hypotheses
now obviously fitness is is the is the
parameter that evolution selects upon
so um to speak of uh restraining
evolution
and to speak of of rocked fitness
landscapes and so on
you actually need to to verify that
indeed
fitness is um is is
is also agreeing with these hypotheses
so what we did to measure fitness rather
than
survival which likely is a very good
proxy for fitness but nevertheless
we performed head-to-head competition
experiments
where we mixed an ancestor strain with
a population that was evolved and you
can generally see in this
left graph that all of the populations
have an increased
fitness which is logic right because
under under our cycle of
of treatment and 19 hours growth they
were all evolved on they all
adapted towards that condition so it
would be strange if if they are not
better
at at growing under those conditions
than the wild type
but there's a nice correlation again
between
the bottleneck and um and
the the relative fitness so the highest
fitness is for the bottleneck that is
the largest
obviously this fitness can can be made
up
of the survival that we already measured
but it could also be that well you have
this 19 hours of growth in our cycle
that something changed
in that time period as well so we we
measured growth
in a semi-automated way measuring od at
regular time intervals for all of our
bottleneck
groups obviously i only show you two
groups and what you can already see is
that while the ancestor it has a dioxic
shift here in the middle
but for the rest it nicely grows over
that time period
the evolved mutant actually shows
uh worse growth right it has especially
after the dioxin
shift there's there's some some
impairment of growth
and if we then do this for all of the
conditions and measure the
auc being the area under the curve we
can see again that there is
a correlation between the bottleneck
size
and the area under the curve but but a
negative correlation meaning that
the cost of fitness which we already
knew
is usually present under drug-free
conditions in high-resistance strains
selected in these evolution experiments
and that the cost is higher
the better the population is adapted
because indeed
the 1 over 10 population is the one that
has the highest fitness
and also the highest resistor level so
the largest cost
in the larger better adapted bottleneck
condition
obviously this was all done on on a
phenotypic level so we switched
to a genetic level because again our
hypotheses
were actually formulated on the genetic
level on this fitness landscape and the
genotype space
so what we did we sequenced all our
populations
really the populations as such at a deep
level
deep coverage we did determine
frequencies of the mutations
and when we aggregated our data on the
left
we could already see that the
distribution within
the populations were quite was quite
different depending on the
bottleneck size so the
small bottleneck populations they
actually had a few
very high frequency mutations at the
right they had
no intermediate frequency mutations
almost none
and they had a very high level of low
frequency mutations on the left
while if you increase the bottleneck
those
intermediate mutants they do occur uh
much more popularly actually at a quite
high
well amounts because these are the
distribution distributions
of those frequencies among all the
replica populations
meaning that likely these populations
are so large that you can have
interference of different mutants trying
to fix but never actually succeeding in
doing so
and well if we look at the specific
targets we see a similar thing
so the left-hand side basically shows
for a low
intra-populational diversity so within a
population there is not too much
diversity it's either in the low bottle
in the small bottleneck condition that
is
it's either fixed or not fixed at all
nothing in between
but if we looked at the target
specifically then
overall we could see that one specific
target
dominated our data set which is the new
new
operon encoding for complex one i will
not come back to
to the mechanism or the the expected
mechanism we have been studying this
mechanism
or this this operon actually for a while
now but this was a very popular
target but if we then looked at how
popular it was
it was obvious that this was a less
popular target in the small bottleneck
condition where we obtained much more
other
highest frequency frequency variant
mutations
so in blue you can see all the neural
mutations
and in gray you can see all the other
mutations or at least the genes in which
they occurred
and the way we quantified this is
basically we we
counted the populations for each
population we determined the most
popular
uh or the highest frequency frequency
variant and and obviously the target
where the mutation occurred in and then
for for all of the replica populations
we basically
compared them and counted them so here
you can see that there's much more
inter-population diversity at lower or
smaller bottlenecks
but you already feel that this kind of a
of a setup is actually not well
controlled
and there are a lot of reasons um
why this is not an ideal setup
for example there are tons of possible
mutations
that can occur so you might even need
more than 40 replica populations to
really make this a
make strong conclusions from this
you're very dependent also on the
sequencing quality and quantity to
detect very low frequency mutations
we only based ourselves here on snips
not on larger rearrangements so all
these things
made us believe that we needed a much
more controlled condition
oh yeah there's a correlation there all
although it's not really uh significant
but this much more controlled condition
that i'm talking of luckily
uh at that point when we were looking at
looking for such a condition
we we were brought in contact by the vib
by its techwatch team
with inscripta with this company
emerging company that was
looking for applications for its uh
for its technology that is basically
still roughly the same as its original
publication
what did they do there they they target
a certain
region in the in the chromosome with the
spacer with this guide rna with crisp
cuff
and at the same time they link the
spacer to an homologous
arm that at the same time then mutates
this region to a mutation of choice
obviously they upscaled this to to a
highly multiplexed
setup where they used computer-aided
designs and
high throughput synthesis of oligos
so that they can do multiplexed
recombineering
in a pooled format creating many many
different mutations at the same time
and this guidernase and this cassette
basically it was provided on a plasmid
so basically those mutants they still
contain a plasmid
with a guide rna that can act as a
barcode to detect
the frequency of mutations in a
selective enrichment
condition where then before and after
the selection you can
basically measure the frequency for each
mutation in a simple way by just
extracting the plasmid and doing deep
ngs barcode profiling and then by
comparing the frequencies before and
after treatment
you can get an estimate of the fitness
of this mutant under those conditions
so inscripta delivered us two types of
libraries
a ko library an e coli containing four
thousand
and something knockout mutants in a
pooled fashion this resembles a bit
uh commercially available
arrayed libraries but this is obviously
much more practical to us since it's
pooled and we can
assess it also in a pooled fashion we
don't have to screen anything
and then a second library the non-coding
rna library
a library of only 87 knockouts
that remove or delete a non-coding rna
gene
for which most of them actually are not
present in literature or definitely not
in a commercial format
we applied two rounds of our selective
regime with
six different bottlenecks ranging from
one to
transferring one to five thousand to one
to ten
um of the of the population and we did
eight
replicas for each of them and obviously
we barcodes
we profiled the barcodes with ngs
and applied count based statistics
in the analysis and when we do so
we actually first looked at
what percentage of the mutants we
maintained
and we can see in the top but also in
the bottom for both libraries we see
that the smaller bottlenecks or the
smaller the bottleneck is
the more of the library you lose which
is logic
in a way but this already indicates that
you get
um by uh
by applying small bottlenecks um you get
a stronger decrease of the
intra-population diversity
and again these things were
significantly
correlated but also if you if you look
at the frequency distribution of the
mutants per population you see the
similar thing as we saw before
namely that maintained
at a very strong small bottleneck we're
predominantly made up of mutants at a
very low frequency
and the higher or the the larger your
bottleneck becomes
the more this distribution shifts
towards intermediate frequencies
now the nice thing here obviously is
that you have these barcodes and you
have these barcodes and you account for
these barcodes
for each of the replica population in
each of the
bottleneck conditions and therefore you
can make correlations
between each population and each barcode
within that population and all of the
other replica populations
of that of that condition so that's what
we that's what i show here for one
condition so you get those triangle
graphs
obviously in the top graph you get a lot
of dots because we have a lot of
barcodes there a lot of mutants
the bottom the ncrna library is much
more
less less less complex but you can do
that you can have actually a correlation
measure for each of those sub figures or
sub graphs
convert convert them to convert them to
a color scale
and even compute an average which is in
the top left an
average correlation value and you can
see that
correlations between replica populations
are significantly weaker
at the smaller bottlenecks actually the
smallest bottlenecks for the ncr and a
libraries
died off but that's nevertheless not a
problem because that same kind of trend
is visible for the ones that did survive
which means that you basically have a
higher inter-population diversity
with smaller bottlenecks and also if you
look
at the specific targets the same thing
is true
right as we showed before so for the ko
library and the ncrna library we had two
very popular hits at the
at the large bottlenecks the one over
ten namely the delta crr and the delta m
icc but this popular target
was less popular in the in the
populations with a with a with a smaller
bottleneck and again this this is
significantly correlating the funny
thing though was that
in the ko libraries we only could
significantly detect
enrichments likely because of the
complexity of this library depletions
could be depleted for all sorts of
stochastical reasons
and with the ncrna library we could only
find depletions
potentially because deleting an rna and
ncrna is very costly in general
now let me conclude
so small bottlenecks we showed that they
impair persistence evolution because
they have a slower adaptive rate they
end up at lower end levels
but they also increase population
diversity and decrease
intra population diversity which both
matches with the rugged persistence
landscape and we also detected
novel genes or mutations linked to
persistence this is shown on the on the
graph or at the right as well but
because of time
i will i will leave that to you to look
at at a later stage or to look it up in
the publication
and for the future well obviously we
want to continue on this
study of of the evolution of persistence
see
whenever selection leads to resistance
or persistence
how this happens why this happens when
this happens
but also look at the diversity genetic
diversity that
remains hidden we believe in a large
scale setup by the very
very popular targets that we initially
pick up there
and i'm also looking specifically at
whether there's such thing as a
cost-free persistence or whether the
cost of persistence is very inherently
linked to resistance
now for the awnings platform the reason
that you guys are are probably here
um the the the ideas are
less i would say so we are working with
the onyx platform that we that we
recently obtained
to make gene saturation libraries
constructing all possible mutations
within one gene on the genomic level
to see which alleles can affect
persistence but also other
traits obviously but we will definitely
also construct more complex
combinatorial mutants and and like i
said
the options are are limitless here and
with that
i would like to take any questions um
that
might have arisen so i give the word
back to to jennifer i think
all right well thank you braum for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
what is the relevance of less optimal
peaks
are we not simply interested in the most
optimal peaks
yeah so so naively indeed i think it's a
very good question but naively you could
say
why why do we want those sub optimal
peaks right i mean
the ones that that make this phenotype
uh
the worst let's say in a clinical
setting those are the ones that we want
to tackle
but that's not always true i mean these
are
very artificial conditions still this is
a lap
environment that we select our mutants
under so it could be that some of the
mechanisms or some of the mutants that
we select are not necessarily very
popular in vivo or not very relevant in
vivo
to do so if we if we can detect the
entire toy room or persistent or how do
you want to call it all the mutations
that
can affect resistance in one way or
another and
it can obviously lead to to a better
understanding and therefore
a full a more complete picture let's say
of of the phenotype
so all right well thank
you very much braum the next question is
there a connection between
ppgp and persistence and
he says also great to see you maybe
someone you know
uh yeah david it has been a long day
indeed david marciano uh
nice for the question and thanks for the
question so is there a link between ppgp
and persistence yes
um so so many many people have found
this link have studied this link
um mostly related to toxins sadly and
and this story has been retracted
recently but still ppgpp the hormone so
the stringent response
hormone has been involved and generally
what we see
is if you remove ppgpp by deleting relay
and spoti generally
what everyone sees is that you have
fewer resistors i must say though
in the mutants that we generally select
in in these evolution experiments
we we don't see these things we do not
see a dependence on pptpp which is a bit
weird because ppgpp is also involved in
the stationary phase response
so upon entry and stationary phase where
we also see an increase in persistence
and
a specificity in our evolution mutants
towards this stage there is an increase
in ppgpp
but if we remove it it doesn't really
seem to matter
um so so is this specific to our
outcome perhaps is it specific to our
conditions
very likely but in general terms people
have this they have studied pptp
dependent
persistence in the past yes
all right thank you so much our next
question
would you predict that the type of
bottleneck eg dilution versus antibiotic
determines the types of mutations that
occur
um when i when i first read the the
question i was thinking no
um so my initial question my initial
answer would be no no because the
bottleneck is the bottleneck
and and i think the way you obtain the
bottleneck does not really matter
in terms of how how the heterogeneity
is affected and how the the speed is
affected
but the types of mutations that you
select could be still
could be still depending on whether you
treat
strongly or less strongly or whether you
just dilute
obviously if you just dilute and you do
not treat at all
there's no selection for for persistence
mutation so then
definitely you would get other mutations
but if you would still combine the two
bit
but play around with the strength of
both let's say
i think it i think it might matter
because if your treatment is less severe
or
much more severe um
obviously it could be that some
mutations are specific for the severity
of of this treatment
all right thank you bro next question
why did you use aminoglycoside
antibiotics
yeah so so the amino glycosides um
they're they're one category of drugs um
that we used
we use that as a start and that's one of
the reasons why we also continue with it
but the better reason to to use a minor
glycosides is
that it's a bactericidal drug to start
with and that it is quite efficient to
kill stationary face cells and we really
wanted to work in stationary phase for
several reasons and i can go into that
later
uh for several several reasons but that
was one of the reasons that
we had to to well we our choices were
quite limited to be honest uh
fluoroquinolones would be another option
um we've not tried that yet in full um
full scale let's say um but the minor
glycosides were also the first where
where basically this evolution
was quite quite reproducible so so that
was one of the reasons as well
all right thank you bro next question
you have shown a graph that shows
disruptive selection in antibiotic
persistence
would this mean that even though the
microbiota that
microorganisms are of similar species
the drugs to kill these microbes will
differ
like a different drug or for another
extreme
so i believe um what what the
the the person who asked this question
means is that that i
have showed that evolution also works
for other species but
that indeed depending on the species but
also depending on the drug that we use
the absolute starting level is a bit
different maybe also the absolute end
level might be a bit different
the reason why we chose different amino
glycosides is just
to make make our conclusions more more
generally
valid let's say but there we do see
different even different end levels
so for example gentamicin we we
see that in the lab as a very very
potent aminoglycoside
resulting in very low levels um
very low levels at the start but also
lower levels at the end
and for the pathogens um yeah there we
chose the antibiotic that at the start
resulted in
in at least a biphasic killing pattern
um for example for
pseudomonas we used i think gentamicin
absolute monotherogenosa started at a
very very low level
with this type of of treatment if you
would use other drugs and other
concentrations this starting level might
differ a bit and maybe the end level as
well but i think by now
because of all the other groups that
also use evolution experiments
the conclusions would largely remain the
same for those kind of experiments
it looks like we have one last question
here brahm
why did you use stationary phase for the
evolution experiments
yeah so so we at a given point i had to
choose anyway but we used
a stationary phase in design of this
evolution experiment
but as i showed you many others used
other setups
other made other choices
the reason that we used stationary phase
is both practical but also
biological practical
because stationary faith if you if you
from one day to another verify a bit
you're still in stationary phase and
although i do realize that
early stationary phase or or or 20 hours
later
that can still matter a lot but if you
are still
changing one or two hours in your setup
it's probably not the biggest
deal while if you do that in exponential
phase or upon dilution in fresh medium
like like the other group
groups do that can can change a lot
another practical reasons that we chose
stationary phase is that if we treat an
exponential phase well we kill
almost all of our cells with these kind
of treatments
and i was already worried in stationary
phase that we would be on the
on the on the edge of what would be
viable because after a while
i do not want to start with 100
populations in flasks
and then after a while only have one or
two viable populations
left so so actually that was one of the
reasons to work in stationary phase
because the levels are generally higher
there
anyway but also because because um it
was also one of the reasons why i worked
in those large volumes then
later ethel proved that that was
actually not so important
sadly uh so i i did a lot of work for
nothing
but then the biology behind it
we i also tend to believe that if these
are very artificial i realize right but
if we continue to study bacteria in mid
exponential
phase then probably the relevance to in
vivo conditions where
mid exponential faith i don't i don't
believe that there is such a thing as
mid exponential phase
i'm not saying that they're all in
stationary phase in vivo for sure not
but to me this sounds a bit
or resembles a bit better what might be
happening in vivo where
conditions are far from optimal to grow
exponentially
so that that's a biological reason to to
use the stationary phase in fact all
right well
thank you it looks like we don't have
any more questions um thank you bro
do you have any final comments for our
audience today
um no no no just that we that we are
very happy with the uh with the scripta
platform and and that's obviously why we
acquired
the onyx uh commercial machine now as
well and
i'm very anxious to see it in real life
uh
i didn't yet because of corona measures
but i will in this in
the near future so i'm looking forward
to it
well thank you again braun van
vandenberg for your time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank
lab roots and our sponsor in scriptdeaf
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during
the on-demand period will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye